[Music]
Bachelorette Becca kufran is engaged to
Garrett
we just got engaged we saw it all go
down on the season finale
Rebecca Joe kufran my Becca will you
marry me
[Music]
the happy couple made their debut on
after the final rose and they dished on
their next steps we are moving in
together we don't exactly know where yet
we don't have any wedding plans yet we
just want to be able to be normal and in
public but yeah we're just so excited
lots of love and happiness there but of
course there was also a fair share of
heartbreaking moments
[Music]
runner-up Blake Sabich Rebecca let him
go there's just one piece but somebody
else that I
I'm not ready to say goodbye to you late
cried into his jacket into a towel and
just straight to the camera just happy
she's gonna be we didn't propose his joy
et was with Becca in May shortly after
she got engaged she revealed her
favorite thing about her fiance we had
so many things so many things just that
he put up with me through the entire
journey the entire time I listened to my
head and I tried to stay logical to a
certain degree but I also just had to
follow my heart
[Music]